we had the twins double trouble
also twin i love yous
and the bathroom floor
i just want it to be me and you this is
you're the bachelor the greatest of all
time
goat lamb sheep whatever you want to
call it the bachelor the greatest
seasons ever
it was the best seasons episode three
recap grab your glasses
it's time for roses and roses
hi everybody it's me lauren zima
and i love you i love you
i love you i love you
i love you love ya
love you i love you
oh everybody this is ben higgins this
season of the bachelor on the bachelor
greatest seasons ever
recap highlight cliff's notes whatever
you want up in college show
and ben famously became the first
bachelor to say
i love you to two women
so right off the bat let's pour one out
for every i love you
he said i love you too i love you too
as you guys can see i have another new
glass today i
kind of if i'm being honest um forgot
about all the bar
wear i had here at my apartment so it's
been fun to
rediscover you know my own dishes okay
and on the note of love roses and rose
everyone i wanted to be a place where we
can come
find a little love have a little
laughter people are on the heels of
being cooped up for months and
i know a lot of you guys are dealing
with job loss
illness and on that note i just want to
say
let's try to come with love on social
media and the comments towards each
other and
if you can try to come with love you
know
so i'm here to come with love for you
guys i love you i love you too
and ben higgins was definitely coming
with love because
he said i love you to two women
at the same time
let's get to it this was the first
season of the bachelor
that i covered for entertainment tonight
so now would be a good moment to pull up
some footage
of baby ben and i me interviewing him at
his first photo shoot
and guess what i did you guys i came to
e.t and i said
here i am this is who i am i interviewed
him
in various characters hi i'm stacy
i'm a bird walker i brought this sign
today
a sign that you and i should be together
i have been
reading your high school yearbooks and
looking through your photo albums i
called your mom
i got a glow up i have to say chrisam
knows
she's looked through old interviews of
mine to pull footage before
and this is when we were in our office
and she turned around from her desk and
said
you look different now she's not wrong
she's not wrong i got rejected and it
still stings
because times are tough let's start out
with a couple sips
don't drink for every time we talk about
ben higgins being unlovable
you could be unlovable he feels like
he's unlovable
but it's ridiculous because it's like
he's so perfect one of my biggest
concerns
the fear of being unlovable that was the
theme of his season
ben a great looking midwestern guy with
a solid job and a fabulous heart thought
he was
unlovable never fully understood why
and i've also never understood why ben
can't say the word
women i've dated a couple women in my
life he's always like the woman
i never could have expected to be with
such an incredible group of women
when he means women i might be the
bachelor and 28 women have came here to
meet me
and ben you famously said i love you
to two women i am in love with
two women here why did i buy all these
glasses with these thin
thin stems you know i'm making gestures
my neck's feeling a little better
not totally there going to an
acupuncturist to try and get it checked
out
but as i'm gesturing about i can't risk
these thin thin stems
i need stemless i need salad oh know
thyself
hi then and you know what cheers to all
of our fun
favorite bachelor stunt moments on ben's
season we had
the mini horse
the chicken enthusiast i think ben's
pretty cute do you
think he likes chickens and
the twins no way hi there
yes we had emily and haley
ferguson twin sisters
oh that glass almost went down oh my god
ben higgins dated sisters two sisters
at the same time so inappropriate
so inappropriate don't drink for every
twin hello
hello hi there hi there would you ever
date someone
at the same time as your sibling
let me know in the comments below
and you know these cliffs notes
highlights low light shows i've been a
little all over the place so
real quick we've got some b-roll of
travel look at all those
destinations i miss places
drink for every place
[Music]
please drink responsibly put it on the
screen
now even though i watched this whole
season it is funny to
see what you didn't remember that you
forgot does that make sense
i'm saying right i did not remember that
kevin hart and ice cube
they literally did a ride along with ben
and kayla quinn and i was just thinking
like why did they do that
and then i googled it and they were
promoting their film ride along
great commentary from them look at this
romantic moment
so funny but i will say i remembered
kevin hart
because he was part of one of the worst
date destinations i've ever seen i love
a hot tub you guys
i love champagne in a hot tub
what i don't love is a hot tub
it's like we haven't been alone all day
seriously
ben kayla and kevin sat in a hot tub
in a hot tub store no okay
i can i can smell the chlorine in the
indoors
do you know what i'm saying it's like it
takes you back to being a child and
going in an indoor pool like in gym
class and you just know that like
everyone's hair product and makeup was
like floating in a film
on top of the water and like the smell
of the chlorine and the tile and like
bleach on the tile like slipping on the
tile and you
fall in front of your friends the boy
you're trying to impress or you're so
embarrassed and like you already felt
awkward in your swimsuit and your hair
your hair doesn't look as great as it
does in the movies when a woman comes
out of the water it's like knotted on
your head
you don't really know how to do your
hair yet and like you're very legally
blind you have contacts at that age so
the chlorine is like stinking your
eyeball so you get out and you're like
blinded and like choking on water
[Music]
i'm fine
anyway but back to the highlights the
low lights and the cliffs notes
they're extreme our emotions are gonna
be all over the place
because now we're on the journey with
jubilee
and jubilee i remember loving her
she had been through so much you guys
and she told the story
of losing her entire family my whole
family
died except for me
and i deal with like a lot of guilt
and honestly i started crying watching
it back you are a
strong woman we didn't have a catch up
with jubilee
but i hope that she's doing well and i
just wish all the best for her because
what a woman to have been through what
she went through and to rise above
and push forward so what is this that
we're coming upon
ben but from tears
to fears yes we are that quickly going
to catapult ourselves into a different
emotional
stratosphere we thought that the
bachelor was constantly bopping our
vibes around well now it's really
skyrocketing
our fields abound because we are in
the water with wild pigs
all of a sudden this like clan of pigs
starts
running in the ocean do you guys
remember this
they went to the bahamas on ben's season
and got into the water with these
wild boar my vibe was jojo
how would you guys have reacted in all
this i mean those animals are large
this is like a bar in dallas or just
pigs everywhere
oh and becca tilly's here we got a quick
little hot second with her i didn't know
i was scared of pigs until today
uh didn't really get much play she was
of course better known for chris sol's
season
but this is the season that bore her and
jojo's friendship so cheers to that
don't drink for every wild pig there's a
pig in the water
but from the journey to learning with
lace
i ruined my chances of bend yes lace was
on ben's season and
she was just in a word
overwhelmed this has been really rough
for me don't drink the entire time she
poured her heart out to bed
is it awkward if i ask you for a better
kiss
do you even notice me do you know i'm
here hello
you didn't look at me once okay you
would not look at me
i watched you i know i'm coming up a
little crazy to you i have a very bold
personality
and then she wanted to pour some more
and asked ben if she could
ben can i talk to you for a second and
he said um
yeah what can i talk to you for a second
yeah yeah definitely
no but i gotta raise my glass to lace
because
she voluntarily removed herself from the
show and what a mature move
i'm mad at myself for
the way i've acted since i've been here
this has been really rough for me
she said i gotta learn to love myself
before i can love somebody
else and i don't know if i truly love
myself to show
and we caught up with her and there
really wasn't much to say about that and
also i will say i don't know if
everyone needs to say what their advice
for claire is
okay what's your words of wisdom and
advice for claire she's about to start
her journey to find love
chris harrison is asking everybody for
that lace was never even a lead on the
show
so i don't know what she would tell her
cheers to lace bye
now ben's season had a lot of
unforgettable woman women
i've dated a couple women in my life but
only one
villain feeling good winning
so we are bouncing around we went on the
journey with jubilee we learned with
lace and now it's
the odyssey with olivia i was a news
anchor
i walked away from a full-time amazing
job that i loved because i think you're
totally worth it at first she seemed
smart
and beautiful and driven but then
she drove the other women away olivia
higgins
it's mine just come on let's just
end the show now i feel it and crashed
and
burned on stage
yes so the show is the gift that keeps
on giving and it often gives us
some kind of talent show group date i
don't remember the specific premise of
this one
and this glyphs notes show didn't tell
us but for whatever reason olivia had to
perform on stage
i don't get embarrassed by anything and
perform she did
ish don't drink for all of this
uncomfortableness
olivia is hilarious is one of those
towns where you want to look but you
know you shouldn't look
it was just rough yeah i remember
watching it and thinking
this is hard to watch i think olivia
chose a particularly flashy outfit
but then didn't really have the flash to
back it up in her moves
so it was just awkward
but even worse was when she
got dumped yes it was one of those
legendary goodbyes i'm gonna have to
say goodbye in a thunderstorm
on a barren wasteland
alone literally you guys it was storming
ben higgins said goodbye and don't drink
for every drop of water that hit the
camera
and don't drink for every wave of water
that spewed up behind olivia
and don't drink for every boat there was
only one
they left her
[Music]
she was just alone out there how was she
getting home
a castaway wilson
well done
i'm sorry but we're gonna catch up with
olivia
olivia thank you so much for being here
so how's she doing
hey i made it through we're okay
what did you guys think of this chat
with olivia let me know in the comments
below
i felt it was okay she seemed
very nervous i'm better now i mean it
doesn't look like it but
i am proud of the person that i am today
olivia sending you love
hope you're good girl and keep on
keeping on
i mean we did have some tough goodbyes
on ben higgins this season
[Music]
we also had amanda stanton crying kayla
crying
i thought this was safe but now we're
gonna catch up with kayla
i mean it is wild to look back and see
some of these people be so
confident like he was the one kayla said
i just feel it when he looks into my
eyes
i want to be the woman he wakes up next
to the rest of his life
he was not the one but now we're gonna
catch up with kayla and
oh great she has found the one i am
actually engaged to a man who's
incredible
i wanna cheers to the positivity of this
she said look
what she had with ben was young love but
she appreciates the show because it
brought her to what she has now
i would have never met nick if i didn't
have my current career
and so i feel like in a way the bachelor
led me to him
positivity come with love everybody come
with love it's not always possible
but we should always try it's been great
i can't believe it's been here
and now inexplicably
i think the transition was from kayla to
kaelin
we're gonna catch up with kalyn and dean
we're talking about their love and they
seem very in love and
chris erison got to the bottom of what
has confused many of us
why is dean wearing a wedding ring i'm
going to ask you guys once and for all
for bachelor nation
are you guys married
dean loves to mess with us are they
really married
and what we learned was oh no no but
yes yes yes dean says they are in love
but they don't want to involve the
government
yeah it's just nice to know that we are
in this strong committed relationship
without necessarily having to
get the government involved testing
likes to say yes that's what i like to
say
great get in that van and get off the
grid babe they're over there on the side
of a
mountain being in love climbing to the
top reaching for the stars
and i say cheers to that okay
oh i don't know if they have a wine
fridge in the van and now
to the final two lauren and jojo
these are heavy i am completely in love
with you
i've known i'm in love with you for a
while as well keep in mind you know
normally on the shows
the bachelor on the bachelorette don't
even say i love you to the contestants
i do love you i love you too
and i remember this when ben
told jojo i love you her face
her face her face
she was like what what
what what i love an occasional breaking
of the fourth wall it was so
real jojo said are you allowed to say
that
are you out of faith
and why did ben say that was he really
in love with two women
what do you think let me know in the
comments below i've always
thought you know i can't understand
because being the lead on the show is
such a unique experience and you can
only relate if you've been
in it when else in your life have you
dated multiple people at the same time
to the point of meeting their families
and all that
but i do think ben probably had love
for jojo and was in love with lauren
and you know maybe he got a little
screwed up from the beginning because he
dated those twin sisters so
inappropriately
seriously it's a tv show okay and then
and then and then
we had the floor
last week we had the door
this week we have the floor
i love this tray i forgot i had it okay
so on caitlyn's season we heard from
nick and caitlin
behind that door
on ben's season we heard from ben and
jojo
on the bathroom floor
look at me i'm sitting here
in a bathroom for being as open
with you as i possibly can be it was so
real
so raw they had to subtitle it
don't drink for every subtitle
so jojo knows and he loves her too
he loves her but he loves her too also
as well and now it's the proposals
that i don't remember why we were in
helicopters
where were we you know we've been
bobbing around we've been missing
the subtitles that we often need on the
show like bahamas is that where we still
were
i don't remember so jojo lands and ben
says
that he loves one woman even though i'm
in love with this woman
i just can't picture life without the
other but he loves one
more i love somebody more and i don't
mean
one more like we know he loves two women
like one more
like one plus one is two like he does
love one more woman like one more woman
additionally but he was saying that
specifically he loves
two women he loves one woman more than
he loves the other woman like one woman
he has a lot more love for them
[Music]
and ben is waiting for her just to cross
the bridge
ben's waiting for you just across the
bridge okay i mean chris harrison had to
take her
and walk her to her doom just across the
bridge
just across the bridge so jojo makes
her speech you've not only become my
best friend
but a man that i have fallen so
completely
in love with and ben who had so many
words
copious amounts of words a plethora of
words to the point of being able to say
i love you to
two women he says i
i uh and i thought jojo was going to
kill ben
yes her face
her face
[Music]
her face
what did you think of how bad handled
the situation let me know
in the comments below but come with love
come with love oh i couldn't even
understand what she was saying
but she did tell him he shouldn't have
said i love you
for you to tell me how love you were
with and then
i love you jojo but don't feel too bad
because we do know that she did go on to
become one of the most beloved
bachelorettes of all time that she had a
great love story and she is engaged to
jordan rogers and they were supposed to
get married this summer and kirsten are
supposed to go but their wedding was put
on hold because of the pandemic but it's
fine long story short they love each
other they have great houses in dallas
everything's gonna be okay so you know
it's fine
was that enough words ben i uh
i do love ben come with love okay
oh and ben was crying ben really is a
good guy you guys he was
just younger and so confused
although then he went on to say more
words
once again more words than he should
have
ben said he didn't deserve jojo
i don't deserve jojo ben said he could
have been happily married to
jojo i could have married jojo and don't
you know
those words probably weren't easy for
lauren bushnell
to here after they got engaged
will you marry me
yeah ben did propose and these two got
engaged and they were together for a
little while but then their relationship
broke apart and i do have to say i think
it was always a bit of a problem
that ben had said i love you two two
women but
you know all's well it ends well because
as we know lauren bushnell is now
happily married to country singer chris
lane and she didn't appear on this
episode she was not interviewed with or
caught up with him i think that was
probably fine out of respect i don't
know i don't know the exact answer but
you know ben is not happily with jessica
clark and it was fine lauren's moved on
he's moved on everything's good so just
you know update we're happy cheers to
having more words with
ben he's here on the zoom and don't
drink for every adjective ben
uses to describe things it was exciting
it was exhilarating beautiful thing were
complicated not always easy this crazy
show not something i want to relive
beautiful person i'm happy for her but
look i appreciated it
he said he had to learn from his
relationships and now he's so happy with
the wonderful jessica clark
and he gave her his final rose
will you accept my final rose
yes and now i'll have my
final rose
i'm not finishing this glass today this
holds a lot of volume what were these
glasses i bought
everybody that has been ben higgins is
the greatest season ever episode
what did you guys think let me know in
the comments below and
know that i love you you can find me on
tick tock
cameo twitter instagram and you can find
me and come with love
because i come with love to you guys we
will be back here
next week with more roses and rose to
recap
jojo's season of the bachelorette and
everybody
oh god
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]